[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
welcome back to joke world the results
are in for round one of the 2020 comedy
podcast march madness tournament if
you're confused on what this is go watch
the video in the pinned comment on this
video but basically it is a march
madness style tournament of our favorite
comedians podcast going on through march
every saturday at noon in the joke world
community section there's going to be
polls and matchups you can vote on to
see who moves on through this bracket so
region one the number one overall seed
the joe rogan experience going up
against the 16 seed trash tuesdays maybe
like a cinderella story here and no it
was 91 to 9 the joe rogan experience
1
600 views on this and my favorite
comment from this poll was josh uh
saying this looks like the globetrotters
playing the high school basketball game
which is true i think everyone saw this
one coming but um the way tournaments
work the the best seed usually goes
against
the lowest seed and then they kind of
even out now the second match up in that
region was uncle joey's joint going
against kill tony which seems like a
little bit more even of a fight but it
was not uncle joey's joint had 83
percent of the vote killed tony 17.
three and a half thousand people voted
on this one all throughout all eight
polls we had over 20 000 voters so i
feel like this is an authentic real
interaction um for this march madness
little tournament but yeah uncle joe's
joint moving on
a lot of good comments uh about kill
tony in here house kill tony no higher
it's literally the best show on youtube
i found out about so many funny people
because it killed tony tremendous how
are the girls tremendous how's the coke
tremendous moving on to region two the
number one seed there was your mom's
house and its first round match-up was
against fifteen seed the honeydew um so
again there were three thousand votes
your mom's house had ninety percent of
them and a lot of positive things to say
about the honeydew in the comments i
know ymh is a much bigger podcast but
sickler is an absolute beauty and
deserved better than this the honeydew
deserved an easier first round match up
honeydew would have been the vote if
sickle cell had been paired with
literally anyone else i threw a subpoena
in the trash
uh a subpoena yeah i'm not doing that
yeah why just didn't want to go did they
ever [ __ ] find you no because it was
a it was like from another state
there's an open file somewhere out there
do not say where to [ __ ] that state
it does suck that the honeydew had to go
against your mom's house in the first
round they have such a huge army of
people online but that's the way that
seating goes so ymh will be moving on to
face the winner of tiger belly versus
whiskey ginger over a thousand people
voted on this one it was a little more
even
not even but a little more even 70 30
going to tiger belly obviously it was
bobby versus andrew the bad friends with
their solo podcast and tiger belly out
did him there don't don't don't don't
back up the back up don't point it back
up there don't point it i want this put
it down i'm i'm going to shoot you with
this put it down put this back up put
the safety on it back up put that back
up dude i swear to god
it's not even on safety love andrew but
yeah he wasn't gonna beat bob in a
popularity contest tbh i watched whiskey
ginge every week regardless of guests i
only watch tiger belly if the guess is
good bad friends beats both though talk
about your chair for 30 seconds
do you mean this chair
from ewin ewin racing gaming chair
i could talk about that for 30 seconds i
still remember the first time i laid
eyes on an e-win gaming chair i thought
i have to have that
the leather
the winged seats
but then i thought there's no way that
holds up to 550 pounds
turns out it does while other
competitive gaming tours only hold 300
pounds the ewing gaming shirt holds up
to 550 pounds so if you are 549 pounds
if you like to sit in your gaming chair
with two or three other people it does
if you like to put big boulders on your
chair because you don't know where to
put your boulders and you want to buy a
chair to put boulders on this is the one
to do it my experience in use with this
shirt has been awesome look at this
little pillow thing this is probably my
favorite part this thing is bad ass
leans all the way back go get yourself
one now lincoln bio ewin gaming chair oh
does your turn not have a neck pillow
dude look full spin
okay back to the results we're now in
region three with this past weekend
being the one seed against chrissy chaos
in the first round two thousand six
hundred votes uh this past weekend with
73 percent of them again first round
match up not going to be the fairest
fight but chris had a lot of support in
the comments 27 was a hell of a fight to
put up against theo sorry chris not a
favorable match up still love you
chrissy podcast for the win love you
theo i love chrissy but theo's comedy's
too unique a lot of sportsmanship in
that comment section but regardless this
past weekend with the dub it'll go on to
face the winner of flagrant 2 against
the king and the sting or the king and
the sting in the wing i guess at this
point so that was actually one of the
most interesting matchups that we had
because it was our only first round
upset the percentages were 42 to 58 with
the king the sting in the wing beating
flagrant two in the first round wow big
upset wow
wow no i'm actually surprised though
because flagrant two was the higher seed
and it was 42-58 so it was pretty close
but all of these comments in here say
negative things about the king and the
sting moving to patreon people are
pissed about that and they have great
things to say about flagrant too maybe
it's because i spelled flagrant wrong in
the poll but i doubt it because you
still knew what i was trying to get at
as long as the words
sound the same when you read it in your
head you can spell flagrant however you
want to spell it there's many ways to
spell every word i love thea but
flagrant 2 is 10 times better than
anything shabb has been in how is andrew
schultz not winning this one's too hard
these two would be in my final four for
sure well it sucks that they had to go
against each other in the first round
but the king and sting moves on to face
this past weekend so it's a thea versus
theo match up there and now we are
finally in region four it starts off
with their number one seed two bears one
cave going up against hey babe over a
thousand votes again on this one and two
bears one cave took it home with 86
percent but that's not to say that chris
did not have a lot of support two bears
is great but recently been listening to
six to seven hey babe episodes a day
quickly becoming my new fave that is
aggressive six episodes of anything a
day unpopular opinion two bears is a
must listen but hey babe is funnier and
more rich in content
i don't know how unpopular that is maybe
a hot take maybe something that no one
said before but i agree with that two
bears is such a must listen and hey babe
hey babe one of the funniest ones out
but regardless two bears one cave is
moving on and they will face the winner
of the keynote matchup of this one the
moment that you've all been waiting for
really what this video was about the tim
dillon show against bad friends now
there are a thousand comments not
literally but there are so many comments
about why is this the first round
matchup this should have been the finals
and like i said it's based on seating so
bad friends was the eighth overall
highest in subscriber amounts out of all
these shows that we just said and tim
dillon was nine and out of 16 teams
those are gonna be the two in the middle
that have to go against each other in
the first round and it was sad to see
one of them go but it made for a great
matchup so let me stop talking about it
and show you the results almost 4 000
people voted on this it was 48 to 52
tim dillon show this was really two of
my favorite shows in the first round and
that's just how it shook out but there
are so many comments defending both
sides
it's crazy how strongly and i don't know
how often these two fan bases really
interact tim and bad friends but it is
crazy
how strongly people feel on either side
of this it's not actually crazy it makes
sense these are two of the best podcasts
but
yet not even close tim is a national
treasure it's a real knife fight out
here this comment from thomas rogers
almost says it perfectly i think tim is
one of the most interesting and funny
people to listen to on a pod but the
chemistry of bobby and cheeto is
unquestionable
that's the part i agree with bad friends
should sweep this tournament i'm sorry
maybe sucks that they had to go against
each other in the first round but that's
how tournaments work and tim dillon's
show will be moving forward yes or yes
so that does it for the entire first
round now the matchups moving forward
are gonna go the joe rogan experience
against uncle joe's joint in region one
your mom's house against tiger belly in
region two this past weekend against the
king and the sting in region three and
two bears one cave against the tim
dillon show in region four so these
matchups the elite eight that's coming
next week saturday the 19th at noon the
polls will be up for you guys to vote on
in the joke world community section i
think that these are a lot more enticing
you know just how tournaments go we're
in the elite eight now so so these
matchups are really going to be getting
into it i don't expect to see any more
blowouts make sure your post
notifications for this channel are on so
you don't miss out on any part of this
tournament and go follow us on instagram
if you want any free joke world stickers
we're sending those out to everyone who
dm's us uh happy march madness keep
voting thank you for the 20 000 people
that participate in round one let's get
it even bigger in round two let's make
this the biggest tournament of all time
let's make this tournament bigger than
the actual march madness tournament
joke world to the moon
[Music]
you